I love thinking about leveraging the
laws of likability when giving feedback,
because feedback is only effective if
somebody can receive it,
so you want to present feedback.
I say on a silver platter and not on a
garbage can.
Lid,
you have to remember it's not about your
communication style,
it's about there's the best way to
develop your people is to flex to them,
to empower them to adapt your style to
what they need.
That's a manager,
that's a leader,
that's a coach,
so if there's somebody who really likes
direct feedback,
even if it's something you're not
comfortable with,
they will respect and be able to take it
in better.
If you can just get to the point,
if you're somebody who's really
directing,
they need a little bit more tact and
diplomacy,
then you're going to need to massage
your messaging.
So again,
it can be heard.
There's a correlation between the speed
at which somebody receives that feedback
and the importance that they place on
it.
When you delay feedback,
you delayed the value you're placing on
it.
So immediacy is important.
Now,
not in the exact moment.
Let them have a moment to breathe,
but don't wait more than a day if you
can.
If it's really crucial you had that
weekly meeting,
sometimes it will fade from your memory.
By that point it becomes less important
to you and to them,
so make sure you give that feedback
quickly and specifically,
don't just say,
oh,
I think it went well.
Tell them why you thought it went well,
what specifically they did that you
thought went well,
and then challenge them with the next
opportunity.
Give them something to keep growing
from.
So if you think about the most important
law of likability,
it's law of curiosity,
and I have a model that you can walk
through any challenging or feedback
conversation that will leverage these
laws of likability.
Starting with curiosity,
curiosity creates connections and
connection is important in these
conversations because when you receiving
feedback,
you're considering your source and when
you don't value trust or like the
source,
then you might not be really willing to
take that information in.
So the model is four parts.
Ask,
elaborate,
empower.
Collaborate.
Ask is going to leverage that law of
curiosity.
Start with a question and make sure that
question is open ended.
It's not,
you know,
do you think that went well,
which is implying that you don't think
that went well.
Instead you asked,
how do you think it went?
What do you think went well?
What do you think could've gone better
and get them talking.
That's the key to opening up a feedback
conversation.
It's get the information from them.
It actually makes it easier on you as a
manager because you see where they're
at,
what they already know.
They're bringing information in the room
and you can determine,
oh,
we're about on the same page,
or we have completely different views of
the situation and that will help kind
tweak the information that you need to
bring into the room.
Oftentimes people are much harder on
themselves than you'll ever be on them.
The next love likability is the most
important thing.
You have to listen,
so listen for the understanding,
listened for the concern,
listened for a different view,
interpretation of the situation,
because we know we're coming in with a
belief about what happened.
We need to try to check that assumption
at the door and listen for other
possibilities,
other narratives.
Alright,
so we've asked.
We've listened.
Now it's your turn.
As the manager ask,
elaborate.
This is your chance to add information
that you might've heard collected from
other sources.
Be additive.
Don't say,
well,
I heard.
Instead you'll say,
additionally,
I received information from so and so
and this and that,
and you're bringing in that information,
my perspective of,
and it could be elevating them.
Feedback isn't always negative.
You don't have to brace them and you
don't have to brace yourself.
Feedback is simply information and it's
information that you want to make
somebody able to use and put into
action.
So that is the first half of the
conversation.
Before you move onto the second half,
what I want you to think about our root
causes,
what are the root causes and the reasons
that it went so well.
What are the root causes and the reasons
that it didn't go so well.
Is there something that's underlying
that can help us in the second half of
this conversation,
what we're looking for,
the solutions?
Did you not have training?
Did you not have authority?
Did you not have budget?
What happened?
Let's evaluate that before we move on.
Now you're going to throw back to the
other person.
You're going to empower them,
get them to throw the ideas out of what
they think the next step should be,
so what would you do differently next
time?
Or how do you think we can move forward
from here are great questions to start
the empower phase
as we empower them and bring those
ideas.
You have to be very careful at that last
stage of the conversation where you're
collaborating because as the manager,
as the leader,
when you put your idea out there,
they're just going to defer,
so builds off of their ideas.
I love that.
I think in addition,
you could also do this or maybe even
switched the order.
What do you think?
The collaboration isn't a dictation.
The collaboration is the exchange.
Now,
another key thing that can happen in
that last phase of the feedback,
especially when things might not have
gone the way that you wanted,
is to leverage the law of similarity
by sharing experience that you went
through that might be similar to what
they're experiencing.
You create a teachable moment.
You build trust.
When you're vulnerable with your
employees,
you actually increase your credibility,
so remember,
vulnerability is not about weakness.
It's about openness,
so share the story of how when things
didn't go so well for you,
what you did,
what you learned,
how it went,
and let them know it's okay.
We all make mistakes and we can still
get to the positions that you're in,
and the last thing to remember is the
law of likability called mood memory
because if they walk away from that
conversation not feeling good,
they're going to want to throw out all
of the information that they've
received.
So mood memory is that people remember
more how you make them feel that
anything that you said,
so ensure that you are being action
oriented.
Feedback is not about berating somebody
or punishing.
We focus on the past to make a plan for
the future.
That's feedback.